straight ahead on lawn crime daily it's
the battle of the experts in a lawsuit
involving a collision in the middle of a
popular ski slope
he said Miss paltrows was impossible
which I believe is false and I think
Miss Paltrow's version is possible
details on the testimony a doctor gave
that completely contradicts an apparent
eyewitness plus was Gwyneth Paltrow
disingenuous from the start one dollar
that's a mischaracterization isn't it
why the plaintiff's legal team is
calling out her countersuit and what
will actually be owed if she wins and
that's not all reports about accused
killer Brian coburger's Life Behind Bars
reveal some of the threats against him
the threat was so repetitive so ongoing
all night long the jail facility had to
take action we're digging into the
intimidation he's facing as coburger
awaits trial for the brutal murder of
four college students lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber expert Witnesses took
the stand on Tuesday testifying about
what they believe happened on a Utah ski
slope in 2016 when a-lister Gwyneth
Paltrow and retired eye doctor Terry
Sanderson collided those Witnesses range
from ski experts to Engineers with
exhibits like animations and even a
physics lesson Paltrow testified that
Sanderson slammed into her back sending
her crashing to the ground Sanderson
says actually she hit him and while she
only had some knee pain that was soothed
by a massage several of his ribs were
broken and he was left with an apparent
brain injury Tuesday officially marked
one week of the trial Paltrow's team
created an animation of what the scene
may have looked like if Sanderson was
the one to ski into her that day a
biomechanical Engineering Group helped
piece together the scenario from
different angles and Dr Irving Shore
walked us through some of it
the first thing to be aware of is this
is Miss Paltrow's version of the events
so that's what we're showing here and as
we move forward I'll talk about the
physics kind of like what I drew earlier
with the center of mass and the rotation
and that's the idea that's what went
into this but again this is not exactly
what happened this is just one of the
possible ways it could have happened in
in this portion there's a number of
possibilities she could be adding weight
to her right ski because of the contact
from Mr Sanderson when you if she waits
the the right ski here more because of
the contact she's going to turn
counterclockwise
the contact from Mr Sanderson if it's
more to the right will turn her
counterclockwise so as they're moving to
the right here there would be some
counterclockwise rotation and here her
ski can catch or she could pitch to the
side or they could both pitch to the
side they could both lose balance we're
not sure what happens
so as she's rotating and he's rotating
counterclockwise they fall to the side
Mr Sanderson lands on his right side
maybe the right back it's hard hard to
say if he lands on his right side kind
of like Dr bam said you know he needs to
land on the elbow that can happen that
can create lateral rib fractures
but that's not the only way his arm
could be out he could land on the side
and create lateral rib fractures he
could land on his side and a little bit
towards the back and Miss Paltrow could
land
as they hit the snow they would continue
to move forward until friction slows
them down
and it's also important to note we
haven't talked about the head injury but
hitting the back of the head or the side
of the head he could have his head
turned all of those are possibilities
for him to contact his head on the snow
so that's not inconsistent as well
the witnesses that were called by
Paltrow's team also helped rebut some of
the testimony that was given when the
trial started last week Craig Ramon was
part of a group skiing with Terry
Sanderson at Deer Valley Resort in 2016
and he testified he had actually seen
the collision and knew for sure that it
was Paltrow who ran into Sanderson but
Paltrow who was on a ski trip with her
family said just the complete opposite
and the expert ended up agreeing with
her take a listen to what Ramon said and
how the engineer reacted to it on
Tuesday
and then I heard this this this BL this
this scream and then I looked over and
then about you know maybe one or two
seconds
um and then I heard a scream and then
and then and then I see this this this
skier just slam into the back Terry and
then when she just slammed him how hard
very hard I mean very hard and so Terry
she hits him right directly in the bag
and so then uh then his skis are like
you can see in your skin like this
because skis his skis actually the tips
go out like this and he falls face down
so he's kind of he's kind of spread
eagle and he goes face down and
gwyneth's on the top of him and they go
down like this and then Gwen hits him
and then bounces off and slides to the
right about five or ten feet well Mr
Ramon's account is very different
because in Mr Ramon's account Mr
Sanderson goes spread eagle and his skis
go out into that V and the inside edges
catch and that changes the cinematics
the motion it's a very different version
of what happens with the contact
all right joining me right now are my
co-host former trial Attorney Terry
Austin defense attorney Brian buckmeyer
Brian it is a battle of the
biomechanical experts who do you think
won Jesse full disclosure physics was
not my strongest sign in school but this
is what I have to say I think that
patrols aside is winning because her
stories match up with Paltrow is saying
matches up with her experts matches up
with the science of what they're arguing
as well as the eyewitness account that
of pound Trove on the other side
sanderson's testimony it doesn't make
sense that he that he got hit according
to Ramona went straight down rather than
sliding down and Sanderson says he went
flying his expert says that's not
possible Ramon doesn't say that he went
flying so even on Sanders and sides
alone there's a lot of contradicting
statements on paltrows it's smooth
sailing from the top of the hill to the
bottom so her side seems to make a lot
more sense Brian is going to miss these
puns when this trial is ultimately over
uh Terry you mentioned that the jury
might be confused about who hit whom if
Paltrow ended up on top of Sanders and
you think the biomechanics expert
cleared that up oh we certainly did in
the beginning I do think the jury may
have been confused because when you
think about it the person in the back is
going to fall on top of the person in
the front but I think that the
characterization of how it happened made
complete sense as Brian said if someone
is coming from behind you and you back
into them and it turns out you fall
forward they fall it you're going to end
up on top if you know she fell the way
she said she fell so I definitely think
that the characterization and that they
met you know the mechanics explanation
made a lot of sense to that jury and by
the way I don't think the jury can
actually use that video as evidence it's
used to help guide them but it's more of
a you know a demonstrative exhibit for
them like ski poles there we go Brian's
going to miss this case it's still ahead
a long crime daily what are Paltrow and
Sanderson looking to get out of this
trial well why the plaintiff's lawyers
are taking aim at Gwyneth Paltrow's
request as money remains at the
Forefront of many Minds
[Music]
and welcome back to Long Prime dally
everybody as Terry sanderson's legal
team tries to fight back against what
actress Gwyneth Paltrow's Squad is
presented during a Civil Trial there's
something that's been brought up time
and again money you see Sanderson is
suing the celebrity for at least three
hundred thousand dollars in Damages it's
up in the air how much he can actually
get but his lawyers say the case is
worth several million dollars in a
counter suit Paltrow sued for just one
dollar plus attorney's fees when Paltrow
was on the stand Friday she was asked
about that and then on Tuesday after
offering testimony on biomechanics and
physics one of sanderson's attorneys
questioned how much the expert witness
was being paid
it's not true Miss Paltrow that you're
just asking for a dollar you
on your side but this is for the court
to decide later you're asking for your
attorneys fees in this case which could
be quite substantial is that not true
so I'm asking for a dollar for me and
then reimbursement of attorney's fees
which is a separate thing and that could
be a substantial amount correct
potentially okay and when your Council
got up waving that one dollar don't you
think that's a little bit of a
mischaracterization I took it as I would
receive that one dollar which is all I
am asking for
eign
450 an hour
500 it's 500 an hour 500 an hour
and you build something over ten
thousand dollars so far for your work
that sounds about right
more than fifteen thousand
so between 10 and 15 000.
now Brian you got some strong feelings
about this I mean what is wrong with
asking for the other party to cover
attorney's fees do it by all means
there's no law against it but as a
person who fundamentally believes that a
person should have a defense regardless
of how much money they have in their
pocket statutes are specifically written
so that if someone goes after you
whether you are the janitor in a
building or the CEO of the building that
you will not have to be out of pocket
for frivolous lawsuits because you have
to pay for your own attorneys imagine
you're a small business owner and
someone comes in and falsifies a slip
and fall and they say I'm going to sue
you for eight thousand dollars you're
like oh man I've got to hire an attorney
for ten thousand dollars and if I can't
get those legal fees even though that I
know that I'm right
I'm going to be out of pocket so I might
as well pay this person eight thousand
dollars that's why this is written into
statues to protect people so to make it
seem like she's a money-grabbing uh High
fluent person I think it's horrible and
disingenuous to do as an attorney I
agree Brian and Terry just going back
for a second you think that uh do you
think that sanderson's team made any
points by cross-examining the
biomechanical expert I think he made no
points at all whatsoever even the point
we just saw about how much he's getting
paid of course he has to get paid and it
wasn't an astronomical amount that he
talked about 400 500 that is reasonable
but I think when you have an expert like
Dr Shear who was amazing on the stand he
was easy to understand he talked
directly to that jury he was
professorial in nature he made it very
clear and the first thing he started out
saying was look the formula that
sanderson's expert used was wrong and so
everything else from that was wrong and
he made things very clear for that jury
to understand that the way Gwyneth
Paltrow did say that the accident
happened was the way mechanically it
could have happened with that bio
mechanical you know expertise that he
has I hope the jurors are a lot smarter
than me because I was lost at certain
points but I'll tell you what coming up
on Long crime daily our coverage of
Sanderson versus Paltrow continues
plaintiff Terry Sanderson takes the
stand in the civil case what he
described that had many at the defense
table looking surprised and Confused
thank you
and welcome back everybody we're
continuing to cover the high profile
Civil Trial involving actress and
businesswoman Gwyneth Paltrow and right
now we're taking a closer look at the
plaintiff Terry Sanderson who testified
on Monday Sanderson took his opportunity
to challenge the claims that Paltrow
made when she took the stand when she
essentially blamed Sanderson for the
entire incident and during the
plaintiff's description of the event he
caused quite a few eyebrow raises at the
defense table check it out
I just remember everything was great and
then I heard something I've never heard
of the ski resort and that was a blood
curdling scream
just I can't do it
and then
and
it was like
somebody was out of control and gunny
hit a tree and was gonna die and that's
what I had until I was hit that's what
was going on in your mind
overruled
that's what's going on in your mind when
you hear that screen
Dr institution oh my gosh somebody's out
of control and they're really seriously
out of control
it's not time for Hockey style I didn't
go think about that but most people
could avoid that I think the good skiers
okay
all right he's overruled thank you so
you hear this screen
what happens next
you know I got hit in my back so hard
and I I'm right at my shoulder blades
and it felt like and was perfectly
centered and the fish and the poles were
right there at the bottom of my shoulder
blades
serious serious smack never been hit
that hard and I'm flying I'm absolutely
flying now you're not airborne
well it all I saw was a whole lot of
snow and I didn't see the sky
so Terry Paltrow's team they objected
when Sanderson testified about the
scream like that the judge overruled it
you think that was the right decision or
just let him talk about it well you know
you think that decision could have gone
either way but I do think it was the
right decision the objection was because
Sanderson was trying to say what was in
the mind of the person who was screaming
but the way he worded it and what his
attorney or was trying to get out there
was that was what was in sanderson's
mind so he heard the scream and in his
mind he thought it meant someone was
coming down the slope and they were
screaming because they were afraid they
were going to have a collision that's
acceptable Under The Rules of Evidence
he can't say what someone else is
thinking but he can certainly say how
that scream made him feel and what he
thought might have been going through
someone else's mind because that's what
he was thinking at the time it's a very
dicey decision but I think it was
probably the right one yeah and Brian I
don't think it was a mistake that when
he said the scream sounded like someone
was out of control that was very
specific language it's like saying oh
the way he killed him was premeditated
you know it felt a little bit like a win
for Sanderson there it all depends it
depends I think as we're getting to the
point in the case where what are the
lawyers going to do consummation to try
to win this case based on their ability
to articulate what this evidence means
now could pouchos attorneys come up and
say what does a scream sound like to you
the jury when someone's out of control
and about to hit a tree do you know what
that is Sanderson didn't describe it
he's trying to pull that out of thin air
because he needs it to show that she was
Reckless is there any evidence that says
that Gwyneth Paltrow is skiing
recklessly no that's his Hail Mary pass
to try to win this case on the other end
it could be do you know when the scream
sounds like people say yeah I understand
what it is and of course he's able to do
that because Paltrow is able to do it
but it's a lot different for a woman to
say a man touched me and it felt like I
was being sexually assaulted as my mind
was progressing and for him to say well
this scream was like yeah he didn't save
himself as much as lawyers thought he
did all right more discussion with this
but when we come back we're actually
going to switch gears accuse quadruple
murderer Brian coburger is still in an
Idaho jail as he awaits his preliminary
hearing and despite being cut off from
most inmates life is far from easy for
them we're going to look at a new report
from inside the jail that's next
[Music]
well there will be plenty more Paltrow
Sanderson coverage this week with
Paltrow's defense case underway but
right now I want to switch gears to
another high profile case that we're
covering and that is Brian coburger the
man charged the murders of the Idaho
four now coburger's preliminary hearing
is scheduled for late June but in the
meantime he's been booked in the late
Tech County Jail in Moscow Idaho since
early January and sources say that gel
life hasn't been so easy for the accused
killer even in segregation news nation
has the exclusive report in on a
one-on-one inmate in general population
threatening coburger through the walls
boy did Brian coburger get an earful the
night that inmate was brought into the
lateral County jail he was up all night
our exclusive sourcing tells us source
with intimate knowledge of Brian
coburger in jail says the threats were
non-stop let me just read them for you
I'm going to kill you co-burger
direct quote from this new inmate
through the walls and through the doors
which Brian coburger could hear and it
wasn't just once it was all night long
and when that wasn't enough that inmate
decided to change course and Target the
guards saying I'll get co-burger to kill
you and that is also a quote those
guards had to actually move this inmate
although in 2000 square feet I'm not
exactly sure where you could move them
but the threat was so repetitive so
ongoing all night long the jail facility
had to take action
Terry on the one hand death threats they
should be taken very seriously right but
now coburger has his own private cell
was that the right solution I
had solutions that they could
does seem as though it's an advantage
for him as a matter of fact there are
some people who want to have private
cells and who try to make reasons for
the security to put them in their own
cell here he has his own television he
doesn't have to share it with other
people whereas the other inmates
apparently do he also if you recall is a
vegan and he gets served these meals
that others aren't getting served so
it's probably fresher so I think all in
all it's a slight advantage to him he's
now in jail so he's waiting and holding
until he has his trial and he is or
isn't convicted so this is just for a
temporary time period but for this time
period it does seem as though he's
getting the best of what he could
possibly get because he now does have
his own private cell and they do have to
protect him it's very serious when you
get threats like that but Brian this is
jail I mean this stuff happened should
we be that concerned about these types
of issues for him yeah Jesse I know we
have a lot of flack for this but I'm
going to put on my public defender hat
yes we should be first of all there's a
big difference between jail and prison
prison is where you are punished after
you're convicted jail is where you're
being held while you're innocent until
proven guilty until those charges or
unless those charges are proven
we have to make sure that the rights and
the protections of all people until they
are convicted and get their just
punishment are protected it reminds me
of a poem the reason why I became a
public defender the they came for a poem
where I'm not going to say the whole
poem but the idea being is first they
came to the Socialist and I said nothing
because I'm not a socialist then they
came for the Communists same thing then
they came after the Jewish people and I
said nothing because I'm not Jewish then
they came for me and no one was left to
speak for me I think if we let this
slippery slope of oh they're just in
jail they're just convicted they're just
tall they're just short they're just
white they're just black if we allow
this concept to permeate then who is
going to be protected against things
that should not happen to people so for
me I draw the line of the accused I
think that they should all get
protection until unless and until
they're convicted and then appropriate
punishment should be given and that is
why Brian buckmeyer is a great great
attorney so well said I don't think I
have anything more to add Brian Terry
thank you both so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America
[Music]